it came for your plastic bags then they
came for your plastic straws since the
theme here if it's an organic polymer
and it makes your life easier
California is against it latest example
the City of Berkeley is targeting
single-use plastic and paper cups having
solved every other problem in town the
City Council there just passed an
ordinance that will require all
businesses to charge customers 25 cents
for the privilege of using a disposable
cup Greg Gutfeld uses disposable cups he
also hosts the greg gutfeld show which
is excellent and co-hosted the five of
course every night he joins us tonight
so Greg this signifies laws like this
the victory over the more prosaic
problems at most cities faced like bad
roads or crappy schools like obviously
Berkeley has already fixed those yes and
you know and I love how this they always
do the same thing they never you know
try to figure out who this might help or
hurt because who uses paper cups
generally working classes that are going
to get a cup of coffee on the street
they never examine the consequences of
their actions because then none of their
actions would be adopted because they're
so terrible there's no proof that this
theft which it is theft will help the
planet it's like if you look at
recycling for example none of the most
of the recycling we've been separating
them in bins now we find out that most
of those bins just end up in landfill
because nobody's actually buying it
think about all that time that could
have been better spent drinking instead
we're sitting there spreading this stuff
out all over the place in the kitchen I
absolutely hate it I am for recycling as
you know if you watch the 5 you hear a
lot of my talking points over and over
again but that's economical it's
economical recycling is expensive and it
doesn't contribute to a better planet
neither does taxing the working class so
it can be so it can make you feel better
again this is another virtue signal to
Tucker you know a person is a symbolic
action that does no good isn't it also
incredibly frivolous I mean if you had a
child and I think our leaders should
care about us as we care about our
children if you had a child who was
addicted to drugs and failing out of
school and pregnant in the seventh grade
would you say you know the real problem
is I don't like this
places you have on I mean isn't that
kind of be missing the point these are
easy things to tackle there's there's a
weird inclination among politicians
these days to ban things it's like if
they actually mistake banning for
productive action when in fact it just
limits more freedom if people you know
the look let's look at the plastic
straws did they think about what that
did to the disabled the disabled need
plastic straws and and they didn't think
about that because you know they thought
oh it's polluting there's an interesting
fact Jim that 95 percent of all the
plastic waste in the oceans comes from
ten rivers eight are in Asia tour in
Africa America is not the offender in
polluting these oceans it's other
countries yet we are doing this and
we're actually harming a segment of the
society that needs these plastic
products there I actually gave you some
hard news well you did it I'm trying to
digest it now but if that's true and I'm
obviously taking your claims on faith I
made it up I don't have the Google
machine in front of me but why wouldn't
we be saying something to the countries
that are actually polluting the
environment why can we be mad about that
because that's no fun it's no fun Tucker
we have to be in the in this in this
left-wing universe especially in the
media we are the oppressors no matter
what yeah so it's like it's it's we are
at fault we have to pay these
indulgences when you find out that it's
China or the Philippines even Brazil is
is more of a pollutant of plastics in
the ocean than we are then it's no use
you can't use it politically against the
United States so why bother
no you it goes back to the root cause
which is self-hatred I don't hate myself
I'd like to opt out of this system if I
was you know I hate you I hate you
enough that's up for you I do I do you
got you got us both covered greg gutfeld
great to see you tonight thank you for
that I wish I could say that to you